[Music]
carlos is in houston hey carlos welcome
to the ramsey show
hi how you doing
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
um all right well i have a couple
questions but i just kind of want to
keep it short um i've been
watching your shows and i actually
started reading your books um not too
long ago so i've been kind of uh diving
into watching all your shows pretty
consistently lately
even through lunches like right now but
i have a little bit of debt well a lot
of debt that i have to try to take care
of and uh it all kind of started a long
story short about three years ago during
uh colgate right before koben i
purchased my house
i got a new car
and um we had gotten kind of
i know it sounds kind of dumb but based
off all your videos you know we kind of
fell into a time share
but it didn't really seem like it was
until a month later when we tried to get
out and it was impossible since then so
i've kind of been stuck in that for you
know coming up to two three years now we
went through so much trouble um i mean
with a lot of details left out we went
through lots of headaches and stress
trying to get out of it and um i
actually got out of the job that i was
currently in that was kind of
getting damaged by coleridge so now i'm
at a job where i'm consistent but i just
really want your advice on how to
get out of this debt work to kind of get
started
i kind of have an idea but
i did refinance that time share into a
personal loan
almost immediately after we did it to
save on interest to save on payments i
just didn't want to be paying too much
but now i'm still stuck with that debt
that after years of contacting them and
calling and and just getting misled
doesn't seem like i'm going to get out
of it so i'm really wanting to see
um how i can get rid of all this debt
and what's the best scenario um as best
so how much debt do you have carlos
all right so i'm not counting the
mortgage um i have about 72 000 vehicles
between me and my wife um 20 000
in loans
and uh 10 000 in credit card okay what's
your household income
uh 75 000 okay you got to sell some cars
fine
yeah like all of them
yes sir
and that's kind of ironic just listening
to your show today even it kind of
pinpointed different questions
throughout the collins and now coming to
my situation that's kind of what i've
been thinking about a lot like i've kind
of figured if i call mr ramsey you know
he's gonna he's gonna tell me that's the
first thing he's gonna tell me so
it's just something that i kind of
wanted some help on yeah so here here's
the thing
uh 75
of your debt
is car debt
we can get rid of three quarters of your
problem
selling two used cars that you can't
afford problem is you love them and
they're beautiful wonderful cars
yes sir yeah what are they
yes sir and uh what kind of cars are
they for
it's a forerunner and a tacoma
you can get great money from that though
carlos thank you the great music the
great news is they're probably going to
sell for more than you owe
actually kind of what i was going to
bring up is i went to a dealer not too
long ago seeing the stress of everything
that happened throughout the years and
they actually offered for my truck uh 46
000
and it's been kind of haunting me in my
head even though as much as i feel like
i can't find this truck again i kind of
wanted to
rely on your advice
and i figured i could just get rid of it
i mean i even thought you know just to
simply sell that truck for what they
want get something that's twenty
thousand dollars less i could probably
put all that into the personal loans pay
that off and use it what do you owe on
that car
uh forty thousand okay well you can't
get something twenty thousand dollars
less you could get something forty
thousand dollars less
we're getting out of that not into debt
so you would be your advice would be to
remove both of them not just one yeah i
kind of wanted to keep
them yeah i'd get rid of all of them
listen you don't need to if you own
things with wheels and motors that equal
more than half your annual income you
got too much invested in things that are
going down in value the only time cars
have gone up in value in the history of
the freaking world is in the last five
months
prior to that they've gone down in value
every year and they will again as soon
as the supply catches up with the demand
and the new cars are starting to hit the
lots again
uh so it's just a matter of time this is
the best time in the world to get out of
a dead gum used car mess and son you got
to use car mess you got to get out of
these things and so carlos too you know
it's it's buying a crappy five thousand
dollar car somewhere yep and you both
drive that but for a short period of
time carlos that's what when you said oh
but i don't know if i can get this kind
of truck again you can i promise tacomas
will be made and you may it may take you
three four years to get it but you can
get another car another great car that
you love again but right now it's not
worth it it's not worth it the stress
and the pain that these have caused you
guys already
it's not worth it so getting rid of that
and i mean
i think it's fun to illustrate this so
you're right he will get something again
so
carlos when i went through this myself
it was a long time ago
but i i was down to one car and a friend
loaned me
a 1978 cadillac with 478 000 actual
miles on it and the predominant color on
the thing was bondo
it was a piece of crap
it was a car that was embarrassing
anywhere in town even in the worst
neighborhoods in town
they laughed at you in every stoplight
driving this car
i drove that car for three months and i
saved up a thousand dollars and got a
considerably better car
this morning i drove in on a classic
1960 corvette that i bought that is one
of several automobiles that i own if you
will drive like no one else later you
can drive anything you want to drive sir
so i'm not bragging i'm just saying that
what i've been doing this a long time
and
i when i was driving that piece of crap
car
i thought the world was coming to an end
and i kind of thought about that car
this morning with the top down on that
corvette driving to work i thought you
know if you live like no one else later
you can live and drive like no one else
this stuff we teach works
over the time that's it and that came
from after being in a nice car
yeah that you were in i was driving a
jaguar that's just thinking i don't know
why
i don't know why your your daughter's
heart just kind of giggles that a jaguar
was like the thing it wasn't a mercedes
but a jaguar
i don't know why mercedes a lot of
people hadn't nobody had a jacket oh is
that what it was it was the unique
jaguars were exotic okay okay so the
jaguar 1981 just saying it well
redneck says jaguar i mean it's like a
thing you know
these are these are words that don't
roll off of a
off of a redneck's lips first what year
was it
it was the first one was a um yeah an
80. okay so 1980 you are you're not
carlos carson i'm not pinning you like
dave but you're driving the car you want
it like he wants us to come like you are
in the thing you want and then the pain
to go from what you want i sold that to
keep it from to go in the bondo car that
was going broke painful so carlos here i
went from a super nice car yep a nicer
car in those days than you've got today
yes into a piece of absolute trash so
that wasn't even mine it was loaned to
me yes so carlos prepare for the pain
driving the crappy car for a little bit
but it's worth it for a short period of
time to get on the other side to get
what you want i did that for three
months that's right but telling the
story right now
my stomach kind of hurts still it was
painful it was awful it felt i always
say i did that for 10 years one three
month period because that's how it felt
like it felt like it was forever because
i mean when everybody laughs at you at
every stoplight there's a lot of shame
involved
you know i just wonder who laughs at
people in cars like you haven't seen
this car this car this you would laugh
at this car if you saw it at a stop
i mean it's just i mean and you're a
sweet person but it's like you look at
that and you go this poor guy yeah i
mean he must be homeless it looks awful
how does he drive that car it's horrible
and the bondo or the uh vinyl roof was
torn loose across the top so when you
fill drove it it filled up with there so
it looked like that was
what was the brown car y'all had when we
were kids that was a mark seven
later on man i remember driving into the
like drop school's drop off line and
that thing the it would bubble up
and you had to like push it up well that
was the headliner did not the top top
on top would fill up there like you had
a parachute on top of your car oh no it
was so bad no that was the headliner in
that old brown one i've forgotten that
and it would like rest on our heads and
we'd be like yeah for about a week and
then i fixed it but yeah i forgot about
that that did happen i remember that
that's the car i delivered books out of
the trunk the first financial piece the
brown car i had a little hump on the
trunk it was a 1985 mark vii what that
so carlos look your future is bright
your car future is bright carlos you can
do this you can do this